how you doing today this is the best you
free [ __ ] interview I've ever had in
my entire life so I can't wait to keep
rolling yeah so I have so many things I
actually want to talk to you about we're
gonna jump in right from the beginning I
am fascinated that you used to do stunt
work yeah when I want to go backwards
real far if I'm not mistaken you worked
on they live I probably did you did well
when you're back you know when you're in
the stunt world back then and I worked I
was one of the fortunate ones you just
go from job to job to job and I'm almost
pretty I'm pretty sure I didn't do that
really well I looked on the always
accurate IMDB and found that you worked
on Roadhouse lethal weapon to Total
Recall Days of Thunder true Last Action
Hero to true romance which was one of
the last things I did with my mentor
Tony Scott and that was a phenomenal
experience write these this is like an
amazing I am I mean just these movies
alone I could spend the entire interview
talking about stunt work and that's what
we're about to do now I'm getting I want
to jump backwards how did you get into
the stunt world let's start with that I
grew up around the business my father
was one of the original members of
stunts Unlimited was came from the
circus first movie ever did was Burt
Lancaster's a circus boy fell in love
with the business and stayed in it and
that was back when stunt players weren't
in the Screen Actors Guild you know they
were background players you know and
they'd actually get a bump for falling
down or doing something or coming in
with their specialties and then it
became a real profession so I was on the
set of things like McHugh with John
Wayne as a baby
paint your wagon you know and it went on
from there and then the heyday of the
big action television shows you know the
Charlie's Angels and the fall guy and
the a-team and you know heart to heart
and all those great old shows and you
know and see all these movie stars I
didn't really care who they were I was
enthralled with the stunt players you
know they were my heroes they're the
ones being caught up you know put on
fire and falling off buildings and
crashing cars and so my inevitable
journey was to start in stunts and I
started a very young age and you know
what dabble was
during school my parents would make sure
that you know my brother and I Scott
would never you know not finish school
so there was always the dangling the
carrot of you will get good grades you
will finish and then therefore you can
work until I was finally 18 and then
coordinating my own shows and then it
was an evolution from there and the two
people that I met that were very
influential in my life was Jerry
Bruckheimer
working with him on Beverly Hills Cop 2
and Days of Thunder and other movies and
also Tony Scott and they were great
because young bucks like me they were
cool about talking to you know and ask
talk and and ok with me asking them
questions about the business and trying
to find my place in the sandbox
you know stunts was the greatest proving
ground it wasn't where I wanted to stay
didn't like being in front of the camera
still not like being in front of the
camera you don't see cameos for me
that's not my bag but I loved I loved
being the person behind it telling the
stories and so I was lucky to have these
people along the way that helped me
define who I want to be and where I want
to go
do you remember what some of the stunts
were on like lethal weapon 2 or Road
house or some of these movies lethal
weapon 2 I remember distinctly and it's
something that I was trying to bring
into angel has fallen I feel like the I
feel like the stunt business now I feel
like the action game now has become too
fake I think that we're in the bigger
faster more expensive Club and so we're
always trying to one-up the next the the
one that the show that did it before and
so what's happened is we are now relying
on visual effects to do things that are
superhuman that no human being could
ever possibly do instead of using the
visual effects enhancement and doing the
stunts for real some people are still
doing it but I wanted to bring that back
as like in lethal weapon too when we
were doing the towtruck sequence where
you know Mel Gibson's gotta chase the
bad guy and he's hanging on a tow truck
there was no green screen we were
hanging off the tow truck you know being
dragged at 70 miles an hour you know
around Malibu and so youyou've learned
to do things safely and I think that the
audience connected with the action
differently because they knew it was
real they knew it wasn't [ __ ] and so
we wanted to bring that to angels fallen
as well of what I had learned in the
stunt world so not bringing my technical
experience but bringing my own
some experience what was it like to be
in the adrenaline rush what was it like
to be in that point of view what type of
fear did I feel hopefully I'm putting
the audience in that same boat yet the
movie Angel has fallen opens with a very
practical sequence so is that one of the
things you wanted to you know making it
so it's not some CGI thing
it was also letting you know that the
movie was gonna be told through the
point of view of Mike banning the first
two movies were event pictures the first
one was obviously taking the White House
plot ribbon the second one was you know
the sass nation of the world leaders in
London this one was gonna be about Mike
banning so for me I wanted you to put
you in his lens right off the bat and
let you know you're gonna go on this
right with Mike banning so it's Jerry
Butler in the action doing the stunts in
the moments as well as the other
character so you felt like you weren't a
voyeur watching something on the screen
you felt like a participant in the movie
to where you can be in that same
adrenaline rush as he was but he was
taking place I have a lot on Angel as
has fallen but I've got to go backwards
one more time I love the Schwarzenegger
movie Total Recall yeah I mean love I've
seen it way too many times
in fact I'm proud to say I've seen it
way too many times what you worked on it
what did you do that is a fog I was that
was down to Mexico City at the
world-famous Churubusco studios and I'm
sure I died multiple times in multiple
places but that was one of those movies
there was a bunch of us that went down
there and it was what was the door was
gonna come up today would you what would
we need was it a fire a gag it was just
getting taking bullets was it a car
everywhere it could possibly be we were
doing it yeah that movie still stands up
though yeah it just lays by the way it
was all real you know I mean tons of
visual effects because it's a sci-fi but
the action was real you know well that
goes back to were you saying when you
were making films in the late 80s early
90s there was no CGI like it is now
no you know there was but it was not the
you couldn't do what you're doing now
no I credit one person that did it
better than anybody when visual effects
became a better tool was James Cameron
by far when you look at what they did
with the Terminator franchise and the
abyss and movies of that of that ilk of
that of that before the obviously going
into
you the the new stuff that he's doing
that's complete animated sci-fi he
always did the action real and then
augmented the stuff with visual effects
to make it look more sci-fi or to build
in facial replacement or certain things
but the action was real the stunts were
real and you felt it and he filmed it
within the inertia of what was happening
versus just again oh you know what we
can just do this easy let's just put all
the actors on a green-screen blow [ __ ]
up in plates and then slap it together
and then you realize no they're not
they're not a part of the action well
that's one of the reasons why when you
look at aliens which is just a
phenomenal film one of the reasons I
think it's so terrifying to people is
when they look in that roof and there
are all those aliens crawling that looks
real because it is real exactly exactly
so my my mantra is to put it in camera
as much as possible there's gonna be
things that scheduling conflicts aren't
going to help you with you know then
you're gonna have to rely on visual
effects to put an actor into a certain
place because they weren't there for
that day of filming there are things
that for safety wise that visual effects
100% help but I'm gonna do everything I
possibly can to make it in camera but
also I think there's this new tool that
just blows my mind how leaps and bounds
better it is now and it's sound you know
the fact that you can actually create a
sound design to where you knew what I
was experiencing sonically as well of
being within fire being inside of a car
chase you know being within a crash what
what was what did it sound like so you
get more of a three-dimensional field of
the action before we're gonna get into
angel I promise but what was how long
had you known that you wanted to write
in direct and what was it that sort of
got you in you know what I mean how did
you get that break well the interesting
thing is is I didn't know about the
writing component it's something I
always loved in school was writing not
screenplays but just writing period and
I definitely had a war chest of
knowledge coming up through the stunt
world about how a set runs how to put
action together how to put scenes
together there's nothing on a set that I
don't know I didn't understand [ __ ]
about the development world and how to
produce material how material actually
gets made
what is the system of financing and all
of that and when I started coming up
through directing you know with
commercials and second units the nice
getting these scripts to direct people
would offer me now of course I'm getting
the worst of the worse I'm not getting
the good stuff I'm getting the getaway
driver script that is just so god-awful
that I thought it was written by a two
year old and I was gullible and naive
enough to go [ __ ] out to write my own
script you know I didn't have no idea
hard that was but I was fortunate that
there were two gentlemen that had been
Pro flip political writers you know up
for Academy Awards won the Academy Award
and I asked him one day I said I'm gonna
write a script and I'd love for you to
read it and if it [ __ ] just tell me why
it's [ __ ] and and and take me to the
school of working writers and they did
it you know and so I wrote multiple
drafts in one year of this a getaway
driver movie that I wanted to do and
finally got it to a point where I
understood what a hook was I understood
what the one sheet was I understood
about character arcs I understood about
tone I understood about structure and
these things that you can't get from a
text book you get him from people that
actually have done it for a living that
way I was apprenticed in stunts to this
day now I apprentice a lot of writers
and I'm part of like the awesome Film
Festival and the working the the writers
conference there and that script ended
up selling called hammer down to
DreamWorks who was Mike de Lucas first
by when he was president there and it
was the weirdest thing that ever
happened because I suddenly had this bug
I loved writing and I didn't direct
anything for seven years and all I did
was write in the studio system and I
wrote like 16 17 scripts around the
studio system getting paid for all of
them not one got made
but it was the best experience that ever
happened to me because I took it
seriously I didn't worry about this
thing called development hell I would
pay attention to the executives I was
working with great producers you know
and and then my career started getting
this point of like as a writer of I was
in the bigger faster more expensive Club
what do you want a professional stuntman
or next man to write write bigger action
and I was getting strictly really really
bored of it and then what happened is my
writing suffered and it started sucking
and I talked to my agent about it of you
know I gotta make a gear change I want
to start waking up in the morning
getting excited not just to being about
money and that's where felon came about
you know a felon was a movie that
started where people would always ask me
what are you most afraid of being it's
not
I was like well you wouldn't be afraid
of doing so if you're afraid of doing
stunts you shouldn't be doing stunts in
the first place right
fear is a good thing but I'm not afraid
of it but I'm always afraid of going to
prison because I have no frickin idea
what happens to in prison and she's like
you should do a movie about that and it
was like a lightning rod because I went
undercover as a parole agent in
California thought it would only be a
couple weeks a parole supervisor knew
that I was a filmmaker but we didn't
tell anybody else so that I can get an
unfiltered view from correctional
officers prison gangsters inside outside
how the system works why violence breeds
violence and that turned into a two year
Odyssey if it was a rabbit hole that
just completely kept opening doors
opening doors opening doors and that's
why I ended up doing the purlins my
prison trilogy you know felons snitch
and shot-caller and so it became this
this trajectory that was where I woke up
in the morning I couldn't wait to get
going I couldn't wait to tear into it I
was working in smaller budgets then the
big big huge action stuff I was working
I didn't give a [ __ ] I rolled up my
sleeves and had a great time with it one
of the things about snitches you worked
with dwayne johnson on that it's back in
2013 or 2012 am i right around there
right so since that time Dwayne has
become Dwayne no like it's his career
has just gone crazy did you have an
inkling back then obviously you cast him
but do you have an inkling back then
that he might become the biggest movie
star on the planet without a doubt and
that's not a [ __ ] answer you know
when you look at him and he and I he and
I really bonded over two men that were
pigeon-holed by the stereotype of what
people thought they wanted us to be him
coming from pro wrestling and he
Hollywood had a design for him and me
coming from stunts I always felt like
Hollywood had a design for me and not
that either of us were against our past
in fact there were war chests that we
would use you know and he uses his
wrestling world and the stuff that he
did there too
to this day and I and I let my stunt
background I'm very proud of it you know
and I guess that's what I'm trying to
say is we're both proud of it but we
didn't want to be defined by it and I
think you're seeing that evolution and I
knew he was a really good actor
underneath the brand of
rock and snitch was a great vehicle for
him because it took all of his
physicality away you know you put the
rock in a box what are you gonna do
choke out the district attorney are you
gonna punch the [ __ ] cop that your
kid goes it does 10 years so it was this
great handcuff device to put him in a
movie that he actually had to be
cerebral and just use his heart you know
to be to be the hero and a different
type of action he ever did and very
proud of his performance in it and I
think that off of that not that that was
the launching pad but I really do think
that as he started going from there into
the fast franchise and all the things he
took on he is doing the movies that he
knows is his brand and what he wants to
be and is and and has defined himself
and I hope that I'm doing some version
of that that I'm make taking movies on
that why I'd want that I want to define
me in my path jumping into angel people
always talk about making a sequel to
something there's always talk about you
know sequels and you know what is it
about the fact that Gerard Butler has
now played this character three times
shows the audience loves this character
in this world because I mean which is so
I'm just curious
what do you think it is about the Mike
banning character that is resonated and
allowed three films to be made one
because he's relentless and we all want
to be relentless in life I mean and he's
not afraid of violence either it's you
know it's a tool it's it's a tool of
trade that he knows but the bigger thing
that I think is interesting is when how
I came about an angel is fallen is Jerry
Butler and I have been friends for a
while and been trying to find something
to do together and we weren't ever
talking about the franchise itself I
didn't even know they're gonna make a
third movie of it and he called me out
of the blue and said look we want to
make a third movie I've talked to
everybody about it we're not gonna do an
event thing in fact I think the original
pitch to him for Angel has fallen was
basically another diehard type of movie
but it was gonna be on Air Force One
this time and he says like I'm not
interested he wasn't interested in doing
a sequel he was interested in doing an
installment something that took a new
direction carried the action-packed ride
in the fun of the first two movies but
took on its own animal and
something different and I was really
into that and his the story structure
that they came up with I loved was
you've got this one-man wrecking crew
that has been in the first two movies
let's put him on defense he's always
been on offense let's take the number
one protector of the President and let's
make him America's Most Wanted and so
they came up with framing him for the
assassination plot and I loved it
because it was able to expand the movie
out of a set piece and make the movie
about the man put him on defense make
Mike banning the rabid dog so you got to
have a fugitive style section of the
movie and then finally when he's gonna
ready to right the wrongs done to him
and try to save the president again and
get the people that screwed him over you
get Mike banning back on offense and he
becomes the guy that you love and so I
flipped over that idea because it think
it became about you get now an origin
story for the franchise that doesn't
feel like a repetitive sequel it's its
own animal and the fact that Jerry had
made sure that they were all good being
the financier is knowing I was gonna put
my stamp on it I was gonna get to put my
wares on it and my tone on it and when
do you get to do that I mean most of the
times in a franchise you're a custodian
of that franchise and there were
responsibilities I felt like a man don't
screw up this franchise okay we have to
have our taking it to let's make sure
we're giving the fanbase what they love
and it can be an origin story but then
let's also build something that can be a
standalone movie in a great entry point
to a franchise where if you hadn't seen
the first two movies you'd come in you
watch Angela's fallen
you dig these characters you're on a big
kick-ass ride and you're like damn I
want to see the other movies and you
know exactly what's going on and you go
for that ride with those two there are a
number of practical stunts there's just
a lot of action in this movie talk a
little bit about obviously you not you
don't have some Marvel budget to pull
this thing off so what was it that made
you the most nervous before filming he
began to try to pull off with the time
in the budget that you had yeah it's
interesting you say that because yeah we
are probably a marvel films craft
service budget you know and it wasn't a
daunting thing to me what it did is it
forced me to say we're not going to
compete with them we're gonna run in our
own lane and we're gonna do what we
[ __ ] do and I love that I love that
the idea that we can create something
super original
and call me nostalgic but I wanted to
make a little bit of an old-school
action movie in a sense that the action
was done real it felt real it felt like
you were in a semi chase with Mike
banning you were in a drone attack with
these characters you're in these
firefights for real
and yeah you augment stuff and and and
bring your modern-day trades you know
into it to make it look bigger and
better but also what I think that the
earlier movies had especially in the 70s
is they had stories they had they had
characters especially the protagonists
that weren't impervious to pain
they weren't impervious to danger they
had flaws they had complexity of stuff
they they were always showing warts and
all and Jerry and I talked about that
for Mike banning to meet a man who has
been a warrior his whole life he started
Army Rangers and Special Operations
fought in the war in Iraq came home the
only thing you know is to hold the gun
what do you go into you go into law
enforcement like many of our military do
and so we went into Secret Service and
now he's we meet a man in crisis in this
movie is can he still carry the gun is
he gotten of age that he cos no longer
who he was is the young buck think of
professional athletes you do everything
in your career to stay in that game and
when it's close to retirement you'll
continue to do things that maybe that
are not healthy for you and not good for
you and lie to people about injuries and
so forth so I thought it was a relation
to carry the paternal relationship of
Morgan Freeman in the movie who starts
as the Secretary of State or the Speaker
of the House in the first movie then
becomes a vice president now he's the
president and the fact that a lot of
time the protector and the protect had
become very close if you think how much
time they spend together and that
loyalty that happens of you're standing
on my watch to be you know to be there
for me in that paternal sense but then
to bring in some new characters you know
let's meet dad for the first time when
Mike's on the road and there's no way to
turn to and you realize his father is a
Vietnam vet who came home was a warrior
just like his son except he didn't deal
with the trauma of war too well and
checked out of society put his head in
the sand and thought he was doing his
family a favor by running away
from them and not infecting them with
his effects of war only to make a Sun
feel abandoned so then you've got these
two great parallel runs of paternal
figures in the movie one Morgan Freeman
the other one played by Nick Nolte and
you suddenly enter we've all of these
great characters who the movie and find
ways to build action in along the ride
that becomes an emotional attachment to
it so when you're with clay Manning and
Mike banning and you're finding out old
bull young bull they have their own ways
of doing things and dads blowing up half
a mountainside it's just not for the
sake of blowing [ __ ] up it's because
dads paranoid and he would have
claymores out there and he would rig the
mountainside because he ain't in the big
brother so you always find these ways
that you hopefully feel that it's
organic to the story there's an
attachment of why things are happening
because I feel like then the levity then
the action makes more sense and you also
more embedded into it and braced into it
completely Morgan Freeman I believe has
played the president a few times at
least once was it deep impact yeah I
can't remember we were laughing about we
he's been asked like there asked like
what do you think about Morgan Freeman
playing the president like we'll see
he's played God he's played Nelson
Mandela he's laid resin I think he's got
this
I think he's played the president though
I wanna say deep impact but I could be
wrong with that it's not Armageddon so
my question is is it possible that angel
is fallen is an alt universe of deep
impact
assuming he played the president in that
film yeah hey maybe we came back maybe
what you don't realize that there was
another extinction period you know and
we're coming back again
right I'm just being stupid it's you
film the movie you get in the editing
room what's the thing that made you most
nervous and what was the thing that you
were most excited by when you're looking
at all the footage most nervous was
knowing that we shot it in three
different countries in multiple places
and making all that feel seamless into
the region of the where the movie took
place it's a big jigsaw puzzle obviously
the thing that made me most excited was
seeing that these performances were
authentic and unbelievable and that you
felt the heart of the movie even from
Gabe Fleming my editors his first
assembly of the movie strung the whole
movie out put everything together and
you can see it and you feel it and
that's what I wanted I wanted
movie that didn't feel mindless didn't
feel like you were disconnected to it
and your eyes glaze over with a bunch of
[ __ ] blowing up but you don't have any
effect it doesn't have any emotional
effect on you I felt connected to this
you know it was funny because you work
on a movie and you know months go by and
then all of a sudden you forget all this
other stuff that is shot and then you
suddenly go into the cutting room and
you watch this longer assembly than the
movies gonna be and it's almost like
going back to class reunions you're like
oh my god I completely forgot we shot
that and you start getting because
you've gotten your objectivity back that
you start finding that you're
emotionally attached things and things
working so that's the great surprise
when you see that you have a cast like
this that we brought in and everybody
brought their a-game and that it all
paid off who ruined the most tapes and
why probably me I am known to talk
through takes you know what if I'm
finding a moment that's going good and I
have this thing where I can cut in my
head at the same time very much less
about how the cuts will be but the
rhythm of the scene and the pacing of a
scene and so there'll be moments that I
know tonally to working really well and
really will just stop them right in the
middle of take keep the cameras rolling
and back up and then go back through
that again and so a lot of times I like
to massage in the middle of takes
especially if I see that actors are in
the spot in the sweet spot they're so in
it to where they're at and there's
something that we want to play with
they're probably me with me for gigs and
I think Jerry would tell you that some
actors that I've spoken to they think
that their first take is when they're
most off most authentic others talk
about how third fourth fifth take is
when they're finding it others they need
even more how how was it on this set in
terms of the way Jerry likes to work and
Morgan and Nick and the other actors
everybody different I would think that
Jerry's jaw dropped when he when I told
him in rehearsals that I don't rehearse
we shoot the first take you know it's
digital why the hell would you not shoot
it and even though 75% of it might not
work there's 25% of magic that's
happened because you're trying to find
it and it's not polished yet and I love
that you know I shoot documentary style
a lot you know with handheld camera
and so when you're looking for these raw
moments these spontaneous moments that
happen they always happen in the earlier
takes because I find anything that goes
past take five something's wrong you
either need to fix it there's there's
something that's not working and then
you keep chasing a dragon and it becomes
more polished and more polished and more
polished and worse and so like the first
day on set you know Jerry shows up and
we started talking everything else and
about the scene just sitting there and
that's go okay picture up anyway wait
what I said yeah picture up let's go
let's go cowboy get in there and I work
that way now people like Morgan Freeman
love that you know Nick Nolte loved that
you know and it was a refreshing way of
don't milk it to death don't burn it to
death get in there and while it's still
organic while it's got some kind of
thing of trying to find itself then it
becomes electric so what's the most
takes you did on the movie did you ever
break ten very rarely I couldn't tell
you what they were they're probably
these the finicky things of a prop
having to land a certain place like in
the action or things like that but as
far as performance wise no I don't think
we ever got to take ten oftentimes I'm
always curious how long was your first
cut compared to the finished film not
bad I got to tell you shot-caller was
two hours and 50 minutes say 50 or 55 oh
okay that's a daunting task to get down
to two hours I'm not the two hour 20
minute guy I like movies that are two
hours or under you know I think that
there's a way to tell that story that
you don't need that extra 20 minutes and
bore the people to death the this movie
I think came in at about two 3501 which
was a really good spot I liked what that
was and if you think about it it was
also the fact that I think there's 20 or
21 action sequences in this movie I mean
if you start counting all the different
rhythms of the different sections so you
start playing with those areas there's a
lot of real estate there that's gonna
absorb itself and start you know coming
down where you don't have to suddenly go
oh my god you know the little classic
I'm saying I got to kill my children now
and these things that are really
precious to me
you know these scenes that were great
but they're just slow in the stew like
it's too much stuff to start pulling out
we didn't have to do that you know I'm
I'm definitely unrelenting on my own
material I will cut and
if it's not propelling the story forward
I don't care I mean I try to always be
that kind of have that type of brutality
in the in the cutting room of never
being precious for example Gabe Fleming
my editor is not allowed on set and the
reason being is I don't want him to see
anybody slaving over the shot for six
hours and then he's put in the move and
he's like it doesn't really work but
she's gonna kill he's gonna kill me if I
don't put that shot because I know how
long they worked on it no watch the
material like the audience would and if
it propels a story and it engages in
audience use it and if it doesn't
goodbye I'm very curious you obviously
again you have a budget how much thought
is there in two and dissever come up in
terms of you know if we make the movie
90 minutes or 95 minutes we have so much
more money and time to do an action set
piece on a crazy level do you know what
I mean like that balance of pressure you
know you know cuz you're the movies to a
quality over quantity exactly 100
percent I thought that a lot with the
movie you know of trying to figure out
the sweet spot that we Jerry and I
definitely and pushed very hard on
everybody that we were not going to be
in the quantity Club not with him
fighting a thousand people and killing
every single one you know that type of
outlandish stuff that you see in movies
today but also not just shooting action
for the sake of action because they
would think we mean more it was we're
gonna pick what it propels the story
tells a story and we're gonna shoot it
with quality we're gonna shoot it
effective so that we can use the the
financial resources we have and the
schedule that we have to our advantage
not to our disadvantage where you're
trying to shoot an action sequence in a
day that should have been three days you
know and and I do shoot fast very fast
but but it's also the fact that you
don't want to be able to shortchange
yourself you got to film with Nick Nolte
mm-hmm I'm a big fan of Nick Nolte so I
have to talk about so you're on set with
him is it every day you're talking about
48 hours or is it every other day the
interesting thing about Nolte this will
tell you everything about Nolte one of
the first things that we shot with him
is where Mike banning is coming up into
the for up into the woods and we have no
idea who he's looking for
and here's this old fart that's coming
out of the woods with a rifle point
right at his head and Nick Nolte's has
been rode hard and put away wet he's got
steel hips he's got a steel femur he's
got he's got we're gonna make a Volvo I
don't feel it eh that he passes us you
know but the interesting thing about him
is he started coming down this mountain
with that rifle and he saw where the
camera was when the camera was a little
bit short of its mark and so he started
to veer and there was these big bushes
or like a big huge tree right in front
of him he was trying to step over and he
was going down and I ran and grabbed him
and I'm like man take it easy goes hey
man I'm all-in so you know and that told
me everything about him that two guys
that blew my mind was Morgan Freeman and
Nick Nolte look at their resumes they
could phone it in right now and still be
good but that both men came in with
their a game wanted to be passionate
wanted to be creative really tear in the
material do something interesting my you
know my whole job was just not to screw
it up with those two guys and so what it
Mays me about Nolte to get in a
roundabout way back to what you asked me
is you do talk to him about those days
and what's interesting is look everybody
always says Nick's like a little bit
crazy you know he's out there you know
and you don't know where he's gonna go
I found it completely the opposite I
found a man that was so articulate so
smart and knew every single moment of
history in his life - talking about
Charlie blue darn at Paramount when
Eddie Murphy was discovered for 48 hours
talking about the scenes in 48 hours
talking about the childhood Street that
he grew up on knowing his childhood
friends the name of the street the
corner I mean it was incredible his
detail of memory I would have loved to
have been standing there was amazing
listening to this amazing these stories
of all these different places the fact
that this is the first movie that Morgan
and Nolte have been in since teachers
with Katharine Hepburn what yeah and
their stories about that I mean just you
when you're the the younger generation
and I would hope to Sam the younger
generation still you know when Jerry and
Jada pinkett-smith and you know even
Danny Huston arrived just poor guy man
I'm a massive fan of his father John
Huston and he and
every day hey so on this show over your
dad would and this thing what you did
with your dad how was this and he just
would smile and tell me these great
stories about his father I'm a I love
history I love history of our business
and Nolte and Huston were my muses
because they put up with my [ __ ] every
day I've asked him every dumb question
in the book I think with teachers 1980
or I should know this cuz they just
brought up in 1982 was it easy to 83 I
can see the poster I think I had no idea
they were in that together yeah that's
it's just crazy I am a movie by the way
like 48 hours I don't think that can get
made in a day today no because of the
you know it wasn't exactly PC 100% and
and but you also look at movies like
that and take take aside the content of
the the you know politically correct
content so to speak or it or not being a
non-political content but the idea that
you were doing these cool action movies
but they had real characters they had
something to say
they had content and relevant themes in
it that made you think hopefully brought
some of that Angela's fallen because
that's kind of what I want to get back
to the movies you know if you look at
the movies that I make they're always in
the moral gray of society they never a
black and white you know shot-caller
would Nikolaj coster-waldau is about you
know violence breeding violence could
you be could you become violent to
defend yourself you know how far would
you bend and change your own moral
compass to do it and I think that an
angel has fallen it's all about these
warriors that were breeding after 9/11
where you're fighting in the longest
combat campaign in American history let
alone the world and you have warriors
that have been fighting for gonna be
close to two decades and you're not
talking about two or three tours you're
talking about multiple dozens of
tourists hundreds upon hundreds of
missions and then they come out and
their brains are wired to be Lions you
know they are nothing but lions
predators that are built and designed to
chase down the enemy you don't come home
and suddenly become a domestic house cat
so what is gonna happen to that
generation of warrior and I think we
wanted to put some of that you know I
did a documentary called that which I
love destroys me that's on that very
subject about a Delta Force operator
that was blown up in bad
after hundreds and hundreds of missions
and he came home and realized that he
couldn't deal with the common society he
was wired to chaos he was wired to war
and he was doing everything he could to
go back into the war which was a neat
parallel that we made with the Nolte
character and the Mike banning
characters here's a sawed father and son
both two warriors from different
generations but much to the father's
chagrin his sons not trying to run away
from Wars
his son is trying to stay in war he's
trying to stay relevant and there's a
whole wave of that going on today so as
much as 48 hours push buttons that it
shouldn't of or maybe was out of the
political politically correct spectrum
of today's world
I think letting some of these hot-button
issues and letting some of these things
fly in movies as much as we're just
trying to make the movie irrelevant
we're not trying to mirror anything it
makes you think about things and make
sure you feel like you didn't get the
dumb down plot listen any piece of art
that can also talk about what's going on
it's one of the reasons I love will
written sci-fi because it's talking
about what's going on you but not being
so overt agree you know um so ah be this
is the third movie with Girard playing
this character
there's obviously who knows what will
happen in the future but did you two
even talk about like where it could go
next because clearly there's an audience
yeah we we were so focused on making
angel and then Jerry and I had a great
collaborative relationship on that movie
and decided we really wanted to work
together again I didn't want to go right
into another action movie with him I
felt like we wanted to make a detour to
find something and then this movie
Greenland came out of nowhere which is
you know it's very much like a quiet
place or World War Z or War of the
Worlds but it's all from the inside out
told them this family's point of view so
that's what Gerard Butler and Morena
Baccarin
and we just finished it we had never had
a talk about any other sequels they to
the to the fallen franchise until
literally yesterday we're sitting with
Morgan and you know Morgan here's one of
the biggest actors in the world and talk
about how great Nick Nolte is in the
movie and just really admiring
everybody's performance and talking and
we were like where would it go from here
and we just said the only thing I can
think of is I want to see these two
fathers with this young guy and the
three of them doing something you know
where you suddenly if you think about it
Mike banning will always dealt with the
two fathers and an angel has fallen
separately they were never in the same
scene I want to see Morgan and Nolte and
Jerry Butler all together and this and
the saddle together I think that would
be a killer movie uh yeah listen I I'm a
big fan of all three of them and I can
already see the dynamic of whom the
three of them talking in a scene it's
Jenna then it's a question of how do you
put the three of them in some big action
set piece together and what are they
doing but I actually want to jump into
if you don't mind into Greenland um talk
a little bit about so you mentioned more
like quiet place so is it one of these
things where we're gonna see Gerry like
kicking ass or it's one of these more
smaller character things much more of a
small character thing the way a quiet
place was really about a family that
happened to be dealing with monsters but
it was much more about the family
dynamics Greenland is about a family
that's trying to atone come back
together it's Gerard Butler a Morena
Baccarin they have a young
seven-year-old boy and they're just
basically trying to heal as a family
when we find out that a comet is gonna
go by the earth and you start doing your
research you realize holy [ __ ] these
things are going by all the time you
know like really scary stuff when you
started thinking how how many near
misses we've had and this is supposed to
be the closest flyby in history since
Halley's comet everybody's excited about
it Super Bowl parties are going on for
it until suddenly they go oh wait a
minute it's changing course a little bit
and some of these pieces are gonna come
through the outer atmosphere but they
mean what do you mean pieces well it's
not one comment it's a belt of comets in
comets to travel and fragments they'll
they'll have hit something and on their
on their orbit and suddenly there could
be hundreds of fragments you know there
are different shapes and sizes and
they're like oh don't worry that this
one's gonna go into the ocean and it
doesn't go into the ocean it takes out a
country you know what a part of a
country and everybody freaks out and
realizes that there are planet-killers
and it becomes this whole thing of now
you only got 24 hours to possibly live
are we in the next extinction period
since the dinosaurs is this about to
happen and we set up that there which
are really there that there are bunkers
in on in Greenland that the United
States built back in the Cold War and
they've been there for generations and
they were built there but if we ever had
a nuclear fallout on the clock
in the United States that we could try
to save as many people as we could and
get them relocated until the radiation
went away and you know we take the leap
of faith that since 9/11 and data
collection and we pretty much know
everything about every citizen United
States that there has been a secret list
of people that you would save to help
rebuild the United States and they would
be people of skill sets you know they
would be doctors they be surges they'd
be structural engineers they'd be people
like biochemists and so forth you know
military the only problem is only 50,000
people fit in these bunkers at a 300
million and so you meet Jerry's
character who is selected because of his
because he's a structural engineer and
it's all about how they would either be
selfish and not take neighbors with them
because they don't have wristbands and
they can't get on these flights how
humanity would face itself in a
cataclysmic situation like this or would
they would would good people do very bad
things with bad people do very good
things and what I loved about it and
again me dealing with the moral gray of
society it just shows if you think that
the movies I made about prison that
prison forces people to act this way and
and either do heinous things or very
righteous things when they're unexpected
no life or death does that and so what
we wanted to do is take this movie make
it feel very grounded and real of how
would we navigate ourselves in a
situation like this when we knew there's
less than 24 hours to live if we didn't
get our families safely to ground into a
shelter it's very funny that your movie
is Greenland with the stuff that's going
on in our country right now yeah the
timing do you sort of wish like man I
wish this was coming out in two weeks
you know I don't think I've ever heard
the term Greenland talked as much in the
last week it's crazy in the last yeah
it's crazy I'm gonna leave it at that
trouble I'm just like it's just
unbelievable the timing um when do you
think who's putting it out by the way I
don't actually know I'll be with STX
okay I will be out next year when do you
think we'll see a trailer or teaser
trailer or I won't even we literally
just finished filming on Monday night
the main unit we have more to film up in
Iceland in a couple weeks so we won't
even have the movie finished probably
until March of next year so I imagine
this will probably be a late summer kind
of like angels fallen or September
October release I'm very curious about
this just because it it's a it's one of
those things where we all think about it
you know the concept of what would you
do
yeah I know does it mean I have to I'll
leave it alone so they don't want any
wood to give away any more plot points
but is it one of these things where if
you're selected does that mean you get
to bring your wife and kid or is it sort
of like just you I'll give you an
example of one scene that just sets the
tone for everything it's the idea that
this guy and his wife and his kid are
selected with wrist bands and they're
parody that they're having that's like a
Super Bowl party nobody else got the
presidential alert nobody else is
getting the wristbands and they're
wondering why the garetty's got picked
and who's Jerry's family's characters
and as they're leaving one of the
neighbors is literally trying to stuff
their child in the car what would you do
would you take the child knowing that
maybe they won't let her on a
six-year-old on one of these planes at a
military base and leave her stranded out
alone in the middle of nowhere or would
you not take her and have to just save
your family and BnB s'more and a selfish
point of view there all of these these
the movie is just chock-full of these
type of situations that are your worst
nightmare to have to to answer the fact
that there is no reverse you either have
to take a child or not take a child you
either have to go to left or go to the
right and the movie is just filled with
these zigs and zags in these crossroads
that will make all of us cringe to think
how would we handle them no completely
on that note we'd thank you so much for
coming in thank and indulging my
questions and I hope everyone goes out
and sees Angeles following this weekend
especially if you want to see a fourth
one I appreciate it you know what I mean